- [Voiceover] All the way
from Hollywood, California
the dating capital of the world
is Date My Son!
And here's your host, Drew!
(applause)
- I'm your host, Drew and
welcome to Date My Son,
Jewish Mom Edition!
Here's how it goes.
We've got three lovely Jewish mothers
(audience applauding)
and they've got three very eligible sons.
And they are going to
compete to get their sons
a date with the lovely Lauren.
(audience applauding)
Hi, Lauren, welcome to Date My Son!
- Thank you.
- (whispering) Jewish Mom Edition.
All right, so it says here
that you're an East Coast girl at heart.
- I am, I grew up in Connecticut.
- Oh, Connecticut.
It says you made So Cal your home
while working as an online news producer.
- I am.
(moms make approving noises)
You're gonna ask some questions,
you're gonna get some answers.
Then, you're gonna pick which mom's son
you're gonna go out on a date with.
Sounds good? Are you ready to do it?
- I'm ready.
- Are you ready to play Date My Son!?
- Hi, moms.
- Hi, Lauren.
- Hello.
- So, if your son and I were at Coachella
and we both lost our phones,
would he be able to get us home?
- My son would so be able to get you home.
You have nothing to worry about.
You know, one thing his
father could always do,
it was as though he had
planted a bug on me,
because no matter where
we were in the crowd,
he found me and he got me safely
wherever we needed to go,
so my son does that also.
- What about mom number two?
Oh, he would definitely
be able to get you home.
He would find somebody, charm them
into lending them his phone
and call an Uber and get you home.
- Black car, Uberx, we
don't know, it's exciting.
He has an extraordinary
sense of direction,
he gets that from his father. Absolutely.
- So Martin Luther King is one
of my favorite historical figures.
Who from history would your son have been.
- I think of my son as such a great leader
and having leadership qualities
and always fighting for the underdog,
so I think he'd probably
be someone like Moses,
who led the people to freedom.
- Let my people date!
(audience laughing)
- My son is such an
extraordinary peacekeeper.
If I'm really thinking
about it I would say
somebody like Gandhi.
Yeah, I know that's big,
that's big, but it's true.
- Even though Eminem is still alive,
I would have to say he
really reveres Eminem.
- I like it, current!
Lauren, give us your next question.
- So tell me what your
son was like as a baby.
- Ohhhh, my son was the prettiest baby,
first of all, what a
punim, I'm telling you.
And such a love and I
really enjoyed breastfeeding
and he did to.
- Mom number Two?
- Well, let's start off with the fact
that he was a ten-and-a-half pound baby.
(Lauren whistles)
So he started out like a three-month-old.
He came out and the
nurses were so astonished
because most babies' heads flop,
he could have looked
around the room like this,
(moms laugh)
checking everybody out.
It was indicative of
how he turned out to be,
'cause he's the same now.
- Awww.
(loud bang)
You know that sound.
That sound means it's the lightning round.
Each mom gets exactly one
word to describe their son.
Mom number Three, go!
- Oh, um, unique.
- Mom number Two?
- Special.
- Mom number One.
- One of a kind.
- That's more than one word, but great!
Sounds to me like you all have
very unique and special sons.
You must be very proud.
(audience goes "Aww")
Well there you have it.
That's the end of the game.
Now, Lauren, which mom
are you gonna choose?
Mom One, Mom Two, or Mom Three?
- Man, you all are so awesome!
And your sons sound great,
but I think I'm gonna have
to go with Son number Two!
(audience cheers)
- There you have it!
Mom number Two's son, Johnny,
come on out!
- Oh, my, whoa!
- There you go, wow, there you have it!
Guys, oh, hey, hey, how you doing?
Well, that's beautiful,
looks like the three of you
will make a beautiful couple,
am I right?
(moms laugh)
A match made in heaven.
Guys, thank you so much
for watching Date My Son!
See you next time!
(upbeat music)